I don't know of any other place in the
West Bank where Israeli soldiers are
escorting Palestinian children on the
way to school in order to protect them
from Israeli set the first years while
passing with the army it was much more
violent if they are far but us they use
this slingshot to us well we started
what was really Blair going Khalil
sometimes all the settlements stopped on
the road to don't leave a space
sometimes they throw rocks a lot of
rocks are rocks as rain falling
the group of soldiers were escorting the
children from to bomb on the way to
school
settlers from my own farm came down and
started throwing stones at them one of
the soldiers would was hit in the face
with a rock and fell unconscious so his
friend who was I guess afraid fired one
bullet in the air this soldier was
court-martialed and sent to prison for
illegal use of his weapon
when I was younger it was afraid a lot a
lot a lot sometimes I don't want to come
to school and sometimes I make excuses
if it was the other way around if it
were Palestinians attacking Israeli
children on the way to school probably
they wouldn't be alive